R
IN OPE HAS CLAIMEDT MILITARY WAT
NEW SATELLIT I
SUHOE NOS  SYSTEMISHELLING A
THISS SES RUSSIA HASISREGATHT'S.
SSIED THISLA
SINC
OF IN THISUB UNABLE TO GETNS HAA
OUND THE
IT
INCREASINGLY PRECAATG ON THE
>> WELL,N,T IN
ER
ROEC
NUR DISAST WAS
BECAUSE OF COURSE THAT WAS JAFTT
AND CAUSIN
IN T DISUR
HEIAN TROOPS HAVE BEEN UNGS RYY
TOWN, 'VLLTHERE., SHELL THE
I WAS IN A VILLAGEOUPLE OF AGO.
RO HSEEOPL
NOOLVICUBER OF
OF THESE RUSSIA
E CLAIRAIATING LEST SATELLITE
IMERY  VER
CLEARLY, AS FAR AS C GOES, THAT
S BEEN NT INCREASE
THE DAMAGE TO RUSSIANLOCAIAARO
LATEST STATEME CFROM THEESIDENT
UKRAINE.
MANUEL  WCH VLADI
REREABSSON IS THE LATEST TO DRAW
ELECIC UKRAI TO
RUSSIA.
THAT IS FRAUGHHNICAL
ISSUES THAT COULD ALSO CAUSE A
DISASTER, ERIN.
>> SAMTHH.
LIVE FROM ZAPOZHON
I G IN NOW
SPECIAL ADSE
FOA FORMER.SMYCER AND HET REEDI
VISIT WITH THE COMMAND AND
DAN, I APPRECIATE YO TN WARNINGG
CHSTVERY CLEAR
N, NO E
NUCLEAR EXPERT SAYPUTIN IS
PLG UCLEARIRTIN DOINHE HE'S CLE
THIS POINT, HE
IT, ANE THAT ALL HE IS FIRIN
THINIAN PORTS ARE .
THE UKRAINIANS STRATEGHIEF IS FE
TRUTH.INTH
ER THEOR
TWO TRUTHS AN
E,ELIEVE ANYTHING AY NOT FIRING
OWN NUCLEAR PLANT WIHE
RUSSIA IS E FLAG
ATTACK.
>> YOU THINK IT IS, TOSIBLE RAM
?RYTH O
JUSTAV D LD ACTUALLYUST HITH
BAY.E SATHE UKRAINIAN NAZIS DESE
HE NEEDS A WAY OUT WIT
AND THISOULDE E
FALSE FLAG ATTACK,M AN
EXO PUS  OUTSAY TH.N RUELVE AND.
NOBODY IN THE REST OF THE
DOES.
SOUKINS INCREDIBLYOBG
YOU'VE GRO
SIDES.ERHAA COUPLE O
PU UNE
DONEENCE
CRIMTANTROLLY RU
PE DCTNE T
DO ANYTHING THER DID
N YING THEELLING OF THE AISE HF.
ON THE STHERE.T FIGHTE
THE BLACK SEE NAVAL FLEET.
A TO RUSSIA, JCKED WITH .U SEE
TO LEAVE, AL.THAT, GO ON CRWAR,Y
G  A MOVE WA
UKRAINS T THERE IN
UKRAINE TO HIDE, THAEY ARE
AT RISK  RUSSIA OK
ANHAS OCCUPI IT SINCE.
D ONE OF T BIGGEST REGRETS
BRIDGES ENN
HAPPENON THEY DIDN- >> FOR CRIM
>>Y
KYIV, TH HTOEIR OWN BRS TO LIBEI
STALLND
BATTLE OIV WAS SUCCESSFUL,
SO I THINK THAGEIS GOING TO BE
BIUS OF PEOPLE GNG
AD THE
WAE DONBASR TO CRI OVE WHAODESSY
CALLWOOFRAINE BY TAKING THE MAJ
CR ATTACKED.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE NOT SAYIN
HOW.
THEY ARETTACKING, YOKN, HE FAL
CK
RUETTING HITTHEY'RE NOT CLNG ON
OFHE
>> WE HAVE NEW FOOTAGE FROM
INE ANTHIS
PIG TO LD W
FIR JETS.
THESE AR TO AT
FICALLY THE KIND T
SSN THIS
, WALE
GIN AT POINT
THEY WOULD PROVIDE
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY SPE LF CO
CHIEF.ISING HIM OF THE E G TO
GET THESE TS>> I CAN'T SPEAKT H
TOPIC.
PONSIBLY WITH PEOPLE WI.I THINK
OVS ISDISCUSSING, THE HOUSE PAS
WHENS OUT OF
A-10 IS LY SLOW AIRCRA EECN AFGE
SYSTEMS.
THE RUSSIAN AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS
AND UKRAINIASIGNIFICANT, AIRCRAO
T PILOTS IN T UNOW.
GRESENENIVE THOSE RCED
IOTO
E MULTIPLE LAUNCH ROCKETPRESIDEO
UKEDN .K FOURO BRIN
TONDT EMINO  C N.